Ross I was just playing Richard
Sherman's comments talking about
thursday night football why is Sherman
saying this does he truly believed
thursday night football is bad evidently
I mean you mostly guys then it seems
like it's 5050 you know about fifty
percent of the guys don't like thursday
night football and the short week and
everything it goes along with it but
most of the guys I talked to they love
the fact that they get the weekend off
after it and what they on the back end
so yeah I'm not only that then you don't
have to practice that week I mean it's
you've walked through monday and tuesday
and then wednesday you travel or if your
home you have another walkthrough and
then you play the game thursday to me it
ends up being a really easy seven eight
days of work i always liked playing on
thursday but why not have a bye week
prior to and then allow you to have ten
days following that thursday night
football my other suggestion is how
about you have to earn the right to be
on thursday night football not every
team gets to be on thursday night
football that you make it thursday night
is a big TV viewing night and why not
make it must see TV that's interesting
perspective in terms of you have to earn
it i think what the way they look at it
is this is the chance for every team to
be able to get a prime-time game and for
us to actually have a chance for those
of people that want it to watch the jags
or the browns or whatever team is on
that thursday night that's the other
thing too is because a lot of people
complain about it you know if every team
has to do a once then what are you
really complaining about everybody has
two at once they understand when it
comes to sherman or guys like that then
is is the economics of it i mean nbc's
paying a lot of money CBS has had a lot
of money and a big reason why NFL
network gets the money it does from the
cable operators is because as thursday
night football it has live NFL
programming so we're talking hundreds of
millions of dollars which you know the
players get let's just roughly say fifty
cents on the dollar to play one thursday
game I mean are you kidding me tell me
what you're asking these guys this whole
time get do a once a year
and your Union gets hundreds of millions
of dollars that goes into the cap as a
result seems like a pretty fair trade to
me if it came to a player vote to decide
this you think it'd still be 5050 who
what every guy voting day and understand
the economics of it or would they just
be looking at whether or not they liked
playing on Thursday it was but how many
of these guys are actually seeing a
bottom line seen a dollar out of this
you know Richard Sherman's getting paid
but you know the 52nd guy on the roster
does he care about thursday night
football do we care about his opinion of
thursday night football we probably
don't care about his opinion of thursday
night football but I don't really care
about Richard Sherman's opinion if
there's no football I mean tomorrow
night I have nothing else to do I'm
going to watch the Rams in the Seahawks
I love that there's a standalone game on
Thursdays if we get to watch and there's
a certain percentage of people that are
like me and that's why the ratings are
decent there's other people that don't
like the matchups because it's the rams
and they stink but i want to watch jerry
golf in seattle and see where i think
about him so i don't really care what
any of the players think because it's
not going anywhere anyway you played
with the Patriots for a little while
Brady yelling and Julian Edelman got a
problem with that no no because nobody
yells at himself more than Brady does I
mean he he goes ballistic on everybody
including himself when he's the one that
messes up you know either that or he's
like you know inconsolable like he was
on that interception he threw in the end
zone against the Ravens and I think
everybody their number one knows he's
the greatest quarterback of all time
number two knows how much he puts into
it and how much he cares now he treats
everybody the same which is why you know
they cut guys like Joey Galloway Chad
Johnson if you're not you know what the
program you're out of there so the fact
that he yells and Edelman and he have
that relationship I think that they
actually are very okay with that good to
talk to you again Ross thanks for
joining us absolutely take care dad
that's Ross Tucker former NFL lineman
works for NBC sports network the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you